even though I was quite comfortable
there I was going to get executed they
said they were going to make an example
of a Westerner and I think I was it so
so I had to there's a time limit there
yeah if you get caught you're finished
you cannot get caught that's what put
most people off I couldn't get people to
go with me I had to go out the
old-fashioned way
which was
um cut my way out of the cell bars
[Music]
it's great to have you back David
obviously we've met before but for
anyone who doesn't know who you are for
new listeners or new viewers could you
give us a brief introduction to what you
are famous for
well I suppose uh most well known for uh
having escaped to prison in Thailand in
Bangkok uh the biggest one they have
there clong Prim
it uh wasn't something
I did frivolously I was going to be
executed within a couple of weeks so it
seemed like a good time to leave okay
now
um we're going to get into that in a bit
more detail but one thing that I
remember about you from last time is
you're the most incredible talker and we
took away the inter the initial
interview we've done with you and ended
up having to make it into two long
episodes because you have a lot of
different very colorful uh experiences
so do forgive me if I Jimmy us through
oh no I can understand that I mean the
only place I never talk is in the police
station
I always like some of my uh work
colleagues took um what was it
one slap to get them talking but five to
shut them up oh okay so let's go right
back to the beginning
um you were born in the UK and then I
believe you emigrated to Australia
well um it was all a family thing yes I
was born in basewater in London I spent
the first few years of my life then uh
there but my parents broke up divorced
and I went with my mother to Australia
with my older sister
so I don't have any really very early
memories of London apart from some old
eight millimeter movie footage of me
learning to walk in Hyde Park my dad was
waving a five pound note in front of my
face and I was making every effort to
grab it I continued that behavior for
many many years afterwards returned to
Australia
um
finished some schooling
um
got really contrasting jobs I worked in
an adult Agency for a while
um but also before that I was got a job
in a cinema now it was the and under
literally an underground place but it
was there that I got introduced to a
bunch of crooks
um some of the girls there had
boyfriends that I used to run down with
um
strange boxes or bits of money or fur
coats and then
wink at me bolt out the back door
pursued by often policemen undercover
ones of course whom we'd misdirect
somewhere
but that Circle they were
um safe crackers
and they really didn't trust Outsiders
and didn't much like the sound of me but
because of I demonstrated a couple of
things by being look everybody was
really very anti-authority then I I
don't mean hostile but
for people now they they wouldn't have
experienced that in the uh late 60s 70s
we were so snotty and arrogant we really
thought we were going to change the
world and that
um the laws were all nothing and the way
to change them was to break them well
that was the kind of vanity we had
so
um when I got to know the safe crackers
uh better there was something really
interesting I mean I didn't like the
idea
you know stealing things seemed a bit
tacky but on the other hand they kind of
all needed the money from the from their
backgrounds and everything but that
wasn't so much the the interest it was
the technicalities of getting into these
things okay
um they used to drill through the top
um having anchored it with the drill
with clamps and and put a kind of little
lens inside a cystoscope used in
medicine and watch the the wheels
turning around this is the old kind of
old-fashioned Hollywood style it was
yeah and
um behind the safe were three discs and
you had to line them up
and they'd once they got in they'd take
the door with them so that the
opposition the safe makers wouldn't know
how they'd got in and it was a
a constant battle between the
manufacturers and them because they've
come across new safes which had Special
Metals in it that was mixed like a a
crunchy nut bar very hard metals very
soft ones so the drill bit would slip on
them snap and you got a sense that
this was almost like a game where
um
they would try something then try to
beat them and they were very loyal to
each other
um
they they never spoke out of school as
it were
um when I got involved with them I'd
only have to if I had trouble I don't
have to make one phone call and people
would appear out of nowhere and I
thought
yeah this this is
kind of better than the treacherous boys
school that I I grew up in and how old
were you at this point
um 19 years old 19. so were you thinking
you were making a conscious decision to
move into illegal activities or at that
point in time and at that point in the
world did it feel like more of a kind of
a bit of roguish fun would you say
I was drawn to it anyway because it was
interesting and um
I didn't really have a lot of fear I
think sometimes what we do or don't do
is depending on how scary it seems yeah
agreed
um I was born with a low resting heart
rate as they say you know if it's
below 70 you're a risk taker I don't
know why that is when the safe crackers
retired they put some of their money
into growing little crops of weed and so
on but profit margin is is only through
importing because like the price
difference is cheap in the source
countries expensive where it sells
so because they couldn't do it they were
almost throwing it down like a challenge
like we don't know anybody who can do
this and I thought well I traveled a lot
um I didn't think it was going to be
impossible
um I thought the odds were in my phone
and I looked it up I went to the library
and sort of researched it a bit and
where were you thinking which country
Well they
um
they were very keen to get some
um
hashish from India or Nepal or somewhere
okay I could see
um it's bulky and there's packing
problems so
um they funded me and off I sailed now
the operation my first operation was so
deplorably bad I'm barely 20 years old
I my cunning plan which involved a big
piece of exported Machinery which had
weights in it so the weights would come
out the cash would go in it would weigh
the same being returned and it was a
piece of Television equipment or
something
that went South immediately when I
didn't realize that I would have to pay
a huge deposit in duty to even bring it
in as a demo machine so forget that I
ended up
in short meeting a guy in a money
exchange
section of a bank I was there because I
ran out and I had to send asking for
more from the boys and I met him and he
wasn't involved in any of this but he
soon became that just
he managed to get me six kilos of hash
I took the
1952 ancient Grundig radio from his
parents house the Shelf there guttered
the thing like a fish
wrapped it up and he had to get cling
film in those days
think of this before you travel
arriving with a suitcase full of cling
film doesn't look good I suppose but uh
wedged it in there and then just flew
back to Sydney
now
you can imagine what happened well
just before we get on to what happened
you know one thing that strikes me is
what year was would this have been this
was uh 77 77 so it's amazing think that
back then if someone was going to India
for the first time now they could go on
Google Maps they could research it or
they could find out who they could find
phone numbers contacts they could be put
in contact with people before they've
even set off whereas you must have at
that age at that time been going in
slightly blind you know touching down in
a foreign country that you didn't know
well no contacts was that not quite
daunting well what was more
um troubling with
um how everything would fail and then
I'd have to
um
you know come up with another plan what
context somebody I knew
um
um there were no bank robber who joined
the hare krishnas and fled to India
right and I had his name and and the
ashram in Delhi where where he was was
supposed to have been
uh I didn't really catch up with him on
that trip but okay sure so so then you
get back to Australia with your radio
that is now full to the brim with and I
get stopped you you did get stopped okay
I could stop because uh I'm I'm on a
British passport
um
and it's the only trip I've ever done
and I'm that age I'd stop me
oh fatherly type was at the Customs desk
now the the systems were different in
those days
um it was Sydney too which is very and
certainly was very relaxed back then
right
he opened the suitcase uh there was
nothing in there except a pair of socks
there's a towel wrapping up this massive
radio
which he lifted up so it was buckled at
the sides little red packets poking out
oh it smelled like a hedgehog for a
patchouliers okay not much of a disguise
um he let me go
he uh put it back looked around to make
sure that none of his workmates were
watching him being so soft
um
and then
turned to me and said
you're going back there
you're going to do this again
[Music]
all right you can take your we'll call
it a radio shall we get out of here what
he thought I realized later was that he
didn't want
the whole grammar of the day
arresting me filling out papers and it
would have been a a long time plus I
guess being a dad he thought if I he's
obviously an idiot you're right if I
send him into Gladiator Academy or it
wasn't really like that in those days
but certainly contact center
um the prison what am I doing um well
I guess uh he was hopeful you know I
whilst out of there must have smuggling
me
but I experienced then what
um I got years later which was kind of a
real Downer after you know having got
nowhere with The Hare krishnas and and
cultivated the shoeshine boys and had my
money stolen at Amex uh by some
Scallywags in Delhi all sorts of Little
Adventures over there in India and
nonetheless made it
it's kind of like that's all there is to
it I I didn't really want to give it to
anyone
um sort of felt like you didn't have a
big moment of no
a bit of money that came earlier that's
handy right uh I paid back what I owed
and settled up for for the next thing so
but once that was started when you sorry
I interrupted you go oh I was just going
to say it to finish it
even though they'd funded me the guys
were very surprised to see me back but
at all at all oh you made it oh because
some of them say oh you'll just run away
with it
uh even if that's what he's doing who
knows what he's doing you know
and then
I could see sitting around you can
imagine there's like a table full of
well like three guys
and then a kind of Darkness shrouded
over that room
I thought uh it's not valuable enough to
kill me you know what what is this mood
why did you bring that
well that's what you've been talking
about
yeah
you could have loaded that with
cane or smack or something
you guys we say nothing but terrible
things about a class or heavy drugs that
don't want to know about it right and I
could read then that wait a minute there
we're all might be guys together and
having fun getting into the safe and
whatnot but there was a kind of
different
it was something a very strong lesson
I'd have to be thoughtful about that
um there could be times where things
didn't work out not necessarily that my
safety was at risk I didn't see it that
way but I knew that there were Ruthless
People right okay yeah
so you got an insight into a mindset
that had been a bit below the surface it
was there I just chose not to see it but
um I then went on to you know refine
everything and Vary everything and then
did you after that first time did you
were you still working sort of for them
or did you immediately
well when you wake up on your own when
things um I picked up and there was
enough money around
out of uh
out of strategy rather than just being a
nice guy I gave my partners a kind of
thank you bonus from the next thing that
I did but I did that all myself right so
it was almost like a yeah separation and
I wanted to go back to the my hippie
friends anyway they were a little less
it wasn't that they were scary but but
that didn't last because they were maybe
friends might be all right but they will
certainly careless and stupid but from
from that point onwards after that
initial Journey was that you then into
the world of smuggling I thought
this won't last forever you only need
one setback and that changes it
I probably made quite a lot of money and
I could have got out
but and I should have gotta you know I
have couriers a leak from one of the the
couriers brought the police to me
and here was the problem with it
it was at first I scattered now I was
married to my first wife then clearly
Italian girl her dad had restaurants I
grabbed her I had a secret drawer with
extra passports in it some money
ended up four plane Journeys later in um
off the Bahamas
had the skipper of a day rent yacht and
take me out to an island and nobody had
ever been on before it was empty sat
there on a towel
I thought hmm
the level of surveillance I had means
it's quite a big operation they're
funded and I checked with a lawyer
before the bigger the money they spent
the more determined they'll be
stay away or go back
I mean I don't know why would anybody do
this
uh well I wasn't broke
um I didn't have to there was no
pressure on me the more I went through
the problems the more attractive the
whole thing is
uh she didn't like it much well again do
you think because it was a puzzle to be
solved because
um
arrogance really we've gone from
basically someone who was kind of mildly
interested in making a group of people
meeting a group of
um safe hackers to someone who pulled
off their first thing and then we've
jumped to someone who has people working
for them and and now is no longer taking
the risk themselves now the police are
on to you and you're on this desert
island well small island and you're
thinking about going back into it was
this like a turning point in your life
in terms of going you know because the
other option I suppose was to go
straight
but were you just more it was that just
not an option for you I'd gone to my
lawyer Ralph
he said look this is what I picked up
because I my travel agent had tipped me
to a couple of detectives that come in
he traveled again while I was in on the
phone okay uh actually they're all
innocent really yeah you know and and
gave him a long list of names
um
they wanted travel details for
and a telephone number which I traced uh
to um
a private office building which had been
rented by state and federal police they
were so distrusting of their own they
didn't want to even run this thing from
um regular police headquarters
my lawyer said well what you sure it's
you
said Ralph look at the list of names
there's 30 there I'm 26 of them
passports are a lot easier to get back
then than there now so you had 26
aliases that you were traveling on yeah
right okay
um and I described where they were he
said David they are funded well
they're not bear this in mind but
although I what they won't get me with
anything
they're funded you think they're going
to walk away after a year and say oh
sorry boss you spend a million dollars
and uh nothing doing
they don't work like that
but this is how
stubborn I was I thought because he said
the only thing you can do is disappear
for at least a couple of years and then
you can come back if that's what you
want
and
of course I had justifications for it I
thought okay I'll I'll build up a bit
more money and then I'll disappear but
um it was only after things went
terribly badly that I realized I
shouldn't play like this anymore
what it was they um
because the challenge just kept coming
so now so did you go back to Australia I
went back to Australia and and when I
retired within three months right but
they weren't waiting for you to arrest
you or no no they wanted they wanted
something solid okay
[Music]
um
I won't go into the long machinations of
it all but
um somebody we knew uh was getting
things from a Thai Courier and he got
arrested he sold us out to the police so
that that The Courier would now come to
us and I always have some solid evidence
right he would bring things but we got
away with that because that was another
challenge but
the police got tired of all this
arrested me
no drugs of course so it was a difficult
case the worst kind of case is that
where there's no solid evidence and in a
way it's better to go to court where
you've got a Smoking Gun and a dead body
on the ground because at least you know
where you are but where there's nothing
tangible and it's conspiracies and this
was a huge trial six months long
what is that 119 Witnesses 6 000 pages
of uh telephone intercept massive thing
won't made it worse too and I think this
was
um
would change things for me
um
the pressure was put on for confessions
but it'd be silly to confess
and you can't confess on somebody else's
behalf can you that's not nice
um
lots of the family were arrested even my
mother was taken and it went oh wow just
to put pressure on uh did she know what
you did oh she had an idea right okay I
mean I used to have bin liners full of
money I'd leave behind the fridge yeah
you don't get that in the cinema do you
not done not a very good day you know uh
because they arrested so many people now
when they arrested our wives and my
business partner Michael his wife just
had a baby it was we had to do a deal
here I didn't want to but I was going to
say I said to Michael look
I know you don't like it but we'll play
to it get the girls out of trouble we'll
Escape that's a good challenge that way
[Music]
um
but unfortunately
um
the intelligence section put an arsonist
Informer in with the girls to get some
information
her fire was lit uh burnt down the
women's prison and my wife and my
business partner's wife was were killed
uh that's awful and so the Informer that
they put in there yeah why did they pick
an arsonist for Daniel writer name was I
don't know why I remember that after 40
years God so that's quite a big that was
oh and and just uh to make things worse
the story put about town to scare the
careers into talking because they
wouldn't speak was that we'd we were
killing off all the witnesses and
starting with our own family where does
that come from
um we ended up in a super max prison
nightmarish electronic zoo with two inch
glass and electronic doors and insane
inmates held 48 death rate 27 people a
year died in that little supermax
going to court in Chains with a SWAT
team taking it it was so
so much
Michael fell to pieces
he was just a wreck he didn't make it
uh he survived the jail but
died when he got out the only way I
could survive all of that was to strip
away everything
I you know I found myself in the
supermax concrete everything's concrete
the bed everything there's no
everything's still just with the tape
player from my lure listening to the the
tapes the bug tapes the microphones in
my house I could play back my life for
the last six months clearly you're
moving from room to room taking
telephone calls she was crying about
something I didn't know what I never
know
and David that's gone immerse yourself
in the worst that they have you will not
survive this otherwise
trial sort of went not so good
acquitted of most things but convicted
enough 10 years
difficult imprisonment
but I
the only way I could deal with it was to
say
did I want revenge that was more my
fault I brought this about I got her in
there I mean a family of a very kind to
me about it considering I wouldn't be
but it doesn't matter
in Chains and super Mech strip it all
away it is nothing everyone is a
potential enemy
everything
it just nothing mattered win the day win
the night I mean this is a place we had
to
fill in a book to get some toilet paper
the showers were in front of them in a
glass box
um if you went on a visit they'd zip you
up and lock you in a suit so you had no
pockets
there was after that and her death I
felt like there was nothing that could
affect me you're wrong about these
things you know we're
human
but I got out and they were there they
even visited me to say
we'll be on you when you get out the
police yeah we enjoyed the old days
didn't you
yeah I said pretending you know and just
to make the point
that they were there when I got out
um
I I'd done a whole lot of Woodwork in
the prison in the last place I was at
carving intricate things making these
really great trick Chinese boxes with
beeswax they intercepted the van that
was taking it from the prison back to my
house and smashed it all to pieces I put
it in a box just to say
don't think that we will never be here
we can do what we want so I decided to
leave
the country I was um
how old am I by then let's work it out
yeah
uh I started all this Mischief when I
was about 18 got arrested at 22.
23
uh
um 16 years
17 years either under surveillance or in
bad prisons got out and I'm under
surveillance again
um so how old so you're number 37 about
37. so that's already
you know that's a big chunk of Life
there but you've lost quite a lot of it
to prison or surveillance well at no
point now were you like okay
and I wasn't a normal person uh really
when I got out because of the experience
of prison
I'd already stripped most of Myself Away
to deal with the death
of the Superman yeah and and watching
people be burnt to death in the place
which was frequent
somebody had contact glue pulled all
over him and then satellite oh God Gods
came in and the other one's standing
there with a Tire swinging it around to
make sure to let him burn let him burn
Jesus Barry's name was
testicles swollen like apples but black
okay he died two hours later in hospital
anyway
um that was regular account to deal with
that I'd already strip things away so
when I got a little apartment when I got
out and my mother had arranged things
for me when they were there when they'd
leave rude messages on my answer machine
when they'd
be behind me everywhere I thought all
right I remember this David it never
ends if you want to survive go back to
the way you were you know in in the
super max Anything Can Happen anytime
but I didn't want to live like that
um
I got a fresh passport and most
elaborate means
um I could spend a week explaining how
that came into existence but I went to
Thailand to pick up some money
I
had three days there it was just before
Christmas I left at that time on purpose
so that
they maybe I thought maybe it's their
weak point that they want to have
families in their life just at Christmas
I've parked my mum's car and and left
the keys somewhere for her nobody knew
were you not meant to leave the country
no no no
licenses oh I see
we're just going to take a minute here
to talk about a sponsor of this show
which is manscaped we were sent a
package to try out by manscaped but
Conor one of our producers is already a
fan of the brand I believe yeah
absolutely I've been using manscape for
a little while now and Ben as you know
it's that time of year people start
asking you what you want for Christmas
and I would say that a great gift for a
man especially one that might have
everything is the manscape performance
package 4.0 so what's in that so you get
the lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer you
get some anti-chafe boxer shorts which I
can vouch for as well as a couple of
other grooming products that smell great
fantastic well it sounds like a
five-star review from uconnor absolutely
so Connor you were talking about the
performance package there's loads of
other great gift ideas such as the
hygiene bundle all available at
manscape.com com and all gifts that men
will genuinely love to receive this
Christmas
if you are a listener of this podcast
you get 20 off and free shipping all you
have to do is go to manscape.com and use
the code minutes that's manscape.com
m-i-n-u-t-e-s minutes
um so why are we doing that the risk is
it worth it I didn't want to play
anymore right I wanted to
uh
see if I could have a something
resembling like a a real life just to
find some corner of the world plan was
to to return to London and oh so you
were leaving forever I'm leaving forever
okay I see nobody knew it
um I had a couple of hundred thousand in
Thailand I thought
um
which I returned to pick up
um now I suppose people say this Crooks
always say this
most unusual circumstances led to my
arrest well they were but then again
they always are aren't they or you
wouldn't be telling the story or you
wouldn't have been arrested
but
um the USDA was involved lots of people
lots of players
uh
no real drugs are found uh they did an
airport sweep and listed me up for like
an ounce of something and a false
passport or two
the money I had just disappeared into
pockets
but those when I arrived there I felt so
free I knew this identity was good I
just like floating on air really I
slipped out of my protective mode you
know that when we stick to the plan and
all right you don't want to leave I
should have even stayed there for six
months just get some sensible view of
the world
but I I didn't uh and as I went to the
airport I could see they were all around
me
and I melted back into the crowd and
disappeared again
I thought well that serves me right for
changing that attitude I'd had from back
in super max and I just glaze over
concentrate on the details
which I needed to do because when I went
to make a phone call later at the travel
agency uh waiting
it was so depressing being thrown into
the Thai prison and I had some idea what
they'd be like
um
people I'd known had been arrested there
I knew this much it never won a case you
never get out well you get out and what
were they arresting you for was it the
the uh the passport
um what did the the the money wasn't I
mean what did they leave 4 000 or
something like that right and
there are airports we put
um I saw the guy walking in with it in a
plastic bag you know whatever people
throw on the floor before they go
through security there was a bit of hash
this usual bits of weed but what they
really wanted was
um this 25 grams of heroin because that
would finish me off
a policeman
um Australian one said
was that yours
yeah yeah sure it was he said I didn't
think so what would you be carrying
around that for I mean if it was 10
kilos I might understand but
but that was enough the death penalty
and was it yours no no no so where where
would that come from if you do they do a
sweep every afternoon at five o'clock
they get tons of it right I get you know
nervous passengers go up and then they
change their minds and they throw it in
the toilet too and were they just did do
you think they believed it was yours or
do you think they were just going this
is we need to give him this bit no no I
think they were using it hoping to that
would be good to hold and maybe they
could get something else find out what I
was up to who I was seeing because I had
met
um somebody who's
whose uncle was a big player right
so
there was there was I think they were
optimistic there might be more Camp come
out of it but but there wasn't but what
difference did it make and I wasn't
really worried about
um those drugs or the death penalty I
wanted to die anyway frankly my first
escape plans from there
had
this I imagine getting out
to find the Privacy to kill myself right
I wanted to go to the dusa Tony Hotel I
knew Which floor and where to get onto
the roof I'd taken photographs from
there many years before
um they were you simply couldn't get a
moment's piece dormitories with 150 guys
in them screaming all night
um
we can't even take a crap in peace in
the Thai prison We're Not Afraid though
of what killing myself well no I mean
I don't know being brutalized by the
guards or the inmates so well I knew
enough about Thailand to to know that it
was a little more comic than than bad
there were very bad things happen they
used to
um they've beaten people a couple of
people get beaten to death every day
there but it's a very big prison we have
to get that in proportion I only wish
they wouldn't use the food trolley to
take the dead bodies out because
um you know they don't clean them up
um and could you speak the language or
were you quite it was a quite different
communication uh not really uh and the
few languages that uh pitch up in my
travels I always found that even if you
know them it's better to pretend you
don't okay
um because they'll talk about you behind
your back you know certainly didn't live
it on there was I I just couldn't see
any point
I'd gone to such elaborate precautions
on this trip
um
it just shouldn't have happened and I
even got away from the airport and still
it happened oh all that confidence that
I'll figure a way out I didn't care
anymore I just had enough
um and I remember seeing an old guy
there
if you had to go to court they put
change on you and um you'd line up on
the ground now this old guy I was
looking at him because I don't know why
a big soundtrack went past he had the
presence of mind to push his head under
that sand truck
and oh it twisted it around popped like
a watermelon being dropped on the ground
oh my God guys very annoyed told the
trustees to get that thing away out of
sight
was that nice thing called it I thought
you Brave bastard you yeah you've got
the guts to do that was it not quite a
disturbing thing to witness no it was
shocking because if you haven't
seen it kind of thing up close and I
happen to be looking
um
it was uh
but that that's how I felt about it but
I was
saved In The End by a con man and people
say a lot of bad things about economy
they do yes they do and they uh you
can't be trusted uh they are rottenness
and they will cheat you just because
they're the Scorpion that's in their
nature
uh but
sometimes they're just what you need and
this rather smooth
um Bostonian American
um who spoke Thai and really knew his
way around and I you know I thought the
somewhere in this huge prison there'd be
an enclave of rich and corrupt
foreigners with loads of money and
there'd be luxuries it wasn't there was
nobody of any importance in there you
know a couple of big sacrifices had been
made but
um
a couple of very rich policemen who were
in the hospital in intensive care but
other than that it was it was just um
the people who reached the absolute
bottom Drifters in Asia who did run
after run and then got sacrificed to the
machine they'd get about four jobs a big
Syndicate there operating careers had
run four times bang they'd shot them to
the police they'd be gone oh God they
will turn told the same story and it was
Joe it was this guest house it was such
and such identical
and um and and at this point had you
been sentenced to death had you received
oh no no no I I was trying to avoid that
yeah once I came to my senses because
the the
Boston con had so many wonderful schemes
medical thing to get me bail and know
some way of a escape with a go to court
I get snatched from there I had villains
come over and and scope out the court
too because there was a way I thought of
getting out of there from the lift that
took you up to the the building uh
snatched from the middle as you go down
changed into a different set of clothes
but they all got scared thing about
um some of our most loved uh and
fearless villains they're pretty good in
the local manner but you throw them into
a place like that where people carry
machine guns and shoot at will just for
the hell of it not so confident they
like the upper edge of being snakes
um so I couldn't convince anybody to
really help and it was just as well
um and two and a half years passed there
in this prison it's a long time it was I
sort of perked up a little bit pulled
myself together started exercising
um got a couple of ATM cards over
hadn't my favorite god
um
he was in charge of the the building
bought myself a room renovated
um so you had you bought a room within
the prison that was just for you rented
that's rented right you know and is that
an official thing that you're allowed to
do
right there are places in the world
where it's official right but you had an
influx of money that you could pay for
special treats you could survive there
on um less than 500 pounds a month and
be king oh wow was this the 70s or the
80s now by the way we're into
um
90
495 19 the 495 because what's reported
about you is that during the 80s you
were a multi-millionaire
um is that accurate
um now what do we call a
multi-millionaires a young halfway with
a million and a quarter on a glass
coffee table and looks around the living
room and thinks I've got to get a sofa
one of these days
um oh goes to the car auctions in the
morning buys a big yank tank with a 427
Chevy engine in it
um
drives it around makes his own car
parking spaces you know we're smashing
the front in backing the other one
pushing the other cars out of the way
um
oh stoned off my head most of the time
uh if I wasn't stunned enough I'd take a
few mandracks just to
colludes icing on the cake
um
so I didn't take care of the money and
the money didn't take care of me so I
guess I'm like the reason I the reason I
asked was because
it must have been quite a stark change
going from a very rich existence to
basically somewhere where
you basically couldn't pay for anything
initially and it was a very poor
existence but I guess from what you're
saying there it's not like you felt like
you were Rich at the time
um I've made that contrast a few times
when I had my first big arrest I
couldn't
as I was in a cold near lightless cell
of blue stone and horse hair mattress
about two inches thick and wrecking a
piss I would think back to the night
before when I had my important to tell
in huge bed and Irish linen sheets and
swimming pool out there and
um and we had to kind of shake off the
contrast but that rubber banding must
must have been hard to take because it's
you're going from basically the
aspiration of almost everyone where
you're talking about just buying cars
outright and having a swimming pool to
a piss stinking bed you know it must be
it was you know it's odd thing about it
was
providing I could see a way out a work a
way out
I didn't so much mind oh okay
um I
really trained myself to expect my
whatever world I built up and and this
happened several times I've done it five
times had a new identity New Life new
surroundings even new people
and dang they're gone
and every time it got worse
um and there was even
Thailand was
desperately important because even
though it was quite comfortable there I
was going to get executed they said they
were going to make an example of a
Westerner and I think I was it
um you know I was somebody that nobody
minded killing
um
so so I had to there's a time limit
there yeah there's nothing like the
prospect of being executed by a machine
gun which is the way they did it God is
that what it would have been wow yeah
you know oh they'd have three guards all
with a bit of string on the trigger and
they'd all pull it once so that none of
them could be
condemned in the Buddhist sense of sin
oh they don't even actually right I see
it caused the bullet that finished you
off oh I see so you're in the Thai
prison you've been sentenced to uh
rather unpleasant death penalty
um
how did you start coming up with this
famous plan for escaping
um
desperation it was the last plan that
looked like it was going to work
um there were probably about 20 plans
considered
um everything from being the
prison held I've since found out it
holds 22 000 people oh my God in 10 sub
prisons uh there's a women's section
there's a young offenders there's a
special reminder a drug unit all of that
um
just a wild place it has everything it
even had a prisoner-run shop where you
could extract you could borrow money
against your account and cash anyway
um one of the plans involved being
welded into a VW Combi van in the
prisons Auto Workshop which would be
picked up early Monday morning and I'd
be driven out and that another one was
um there were several courtroom ones and
you couldn't just pay your way out no no
it's just you could pay to have
a mobile phone which in those days was a
rare thing but they were around
um you could pay for a bottle of clong
uh whiskey you could pay I'm sure you
could pay to get a a girl in your room
if you could work out what a room was
that a whole section full of ladyboys
there and got a building full of them
they used to open it up on Saturdays so
um you could pay for anything but not to
leave
they couldn't cover that and they
couldn't trust each other you would need
25 30 different guards paid off and and
the gods of visitors I mean too many
guides no that wouldn't work
and they looked at it as a kind of
betrayal only if I saw two escapes
attempts there one group of uh straight
kids and a Singaporean
got out of their cell incredibly
turned themselves into the sleeping God
when they'd all lied to each other about
what they didn't have you know the ropes
and ways out because they're
it was so outraged that they'd spoiled
the guys jobs they beat them to death
slowly tortured them over three months
to death having put them in little code
lockers the soy they call them drag them
out in elephant chains every day and
batter them senseless
uh internal bleeding usually did it
um
look I've got a bowl of rice and a
painting to poo in that was it
um even the water was it was just too
horrible so if you get caught you're
finished you cannot get caught that's
what put most people off even my Swedish
friends Sten the Viking he backed out at
the last minute I couldn't get people to
go with me
all the other plants had fallen to bits
because they depended on other people I
had to go out the old-fashioned way
which was
um cut my way out of the cell bars and I
needed equipment for that and here's a
really
important point I guess as bad as this
world is you've got to try to find
good people
if you ask somebody if you asked your
friend yeah and and you're finished
you'll manage to get a phone call and
say
friend it's been here
um I need you to get
um I don't know four hacksaw blades and
cut them into the dowel rods of a of a
poster and then paint it all up and send
it in a huge package with this that
cable ties gaffer tape but disguise all
that how many people are going to do it
turn around
wouldn't believe it Ben called me what
his neck yeah he's screwed but anyway he
wouldn't believe but he wants me to do
this that now people don't do it but
Michael on the other hand our business
partner wouldn't even let me explain he
hadn't heard from me in 18 months
he said David
don't explain
I'm sure we could get cut off tell me
the important part now where do I have
to be and what do I have to bring no
that's a friend
um and so I've always tried to do the
same for the others that I've known like
that
um but
um I did get the equipment together that
I needed and everything
um about escapes from a big prison is
not like your hope it's going to be you
know I turned it out walked around the
streets and it had streets inside it
um and timed it with my trusty Casio
and it was
so I knew roughly how long it would take
to get me but the night's a different
world I'm a prisoner I'm only used to
noise during the day even the fan
chopping around in the Cell at night
it's so quiet everything I did squeaked
and rattled and twisted I came across a
panel that had to be a nail had to come
out and that and they'll protest it and
scream their wrench out of the way it
took
um uh seven or eight worlds uh sorry
seven or eight walls to cross over
I say worlds because they really were
every building was a different thing and
I got lost and I went past the terminal
AIDS Ward that building hundreds of guys
all die
and I could smell it before I got there
because this necrotic Rotting Flesh
and I couldn't resist looking in I'm
carrying this huge long ladder made out
of bamboo poles and
fake picture frames gaffer taped along
the center
[Music]
um
and I looked up and I saw all these
little faces in the Moonlight wrapped in
so much pain and despair they didn't
have the energy to cry out to the guards
if they'd been in any other prisoners
they would have the trustees there were
absolute scum of the earth had whistled
little uniforms
sell the drugs one day and the rest of
the guys for it the next all of that
um
and it was only by
um
well I only got to the outer wall by
Dawn and if somebody had been with me I
wouldn't have made it either you
wouldn't have no imagine I've taken all
night to get there and at each point
where this
something was unexpected
I've had to dream up something and I get
a little basic toolkit and I sometimes
I'd have to sacrifice part of my ladder
to make a hook to pull down barbed wire
and the technique for using the thing
was awkward you had to prop it walk up
drop down the other side so you're
twisting over the walls like that manual
is entirely barbed wire so I had to go
underneath it covered in mud the the
last one was really too high
and there was a Mars bar Creek the the
moat that ran around I did you know if I
was with somebody else we'd be arguing
wouldn't we oh Spa Creek oh it was full
of turds bombing around it was caught
out of the sewer
yeah
you did ask
um
illustrative
okay we're just gonna take a quick break
from the show to talk about a sponsor of
this episode better help better help is
an online Counseling Service which
connects people to therapists and
counselors I'm joined by one of our
producers bryony is counseling something
you've had experience with do you know
what it's interesting because when I was
growing up the same kind of challenges
in life would happen but people wouldn't
necessarily go to therapy or talk about
therapy and I feel like since uh maybe
my late teens early 20s people are
starting to go to therapy and talking
about it and I have definitely used it
in my life and it's been massively
beneficial same and do you because I
think one of the things that people
often mistake they think it's just for
big things yeah but what's the other
experience of that thing I think life
always throws you know small challenges
and large challenges and sometimes the
big things need talking about but
actually you know starting a new school
or starting a new job can rile up that
same level of anxiety and it's just
really helpful to be able to talk to
someone about it who is completely
impartial not involved in your life and
just kind of a safe space I guess to
just say whatever you want to say you
completely agree as the world's largest
therapy service better help as much 3
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 of your first month at
betterhelp.com minutes with that's
betterhelp help help.com minutes with
um now there was one way of oh Beyond
marsburg create this a foot and a half
of land before this huge huge wall
you've got to get a ladder that's
too heavy to carry too imbalanced to do
anything with but you've got a bit of
rope how do you get it to the other side
of Mars bar which has all got tangled
barb wire in that so it'll catch
get it in place and up against the wall
when you've got no ground to to walk on
now there is a way
and uh
I guess people have to listen to me
describe it either to you or in my book
okay fine but too long to tell here sure
but
um I could see the glow of dawn as I got
to the top which had electricity running
through it too just to make it the top
of the wall dead yeah yeah wow but um my
friend who um was in there a bit of a
technician is to belong to the anarchist
Society in in Britain
how would you belong to a society that
has rules when you anyway
putting that aside he did tell me that
it would only be 240 volts but to be
careful
um
and just managed to get over that and
because the original plan was to
um oh there was an outer moat beyond
that of 20 meters I had my clothes ready
to go into a plastic bag swim the moat
but just as well I didn't
um because all it turned out all the
guards houses were over the other side
of that moat this would not be a place
to go but I cleaned myself up
threw some clothes on and I one of the
jobs that I didn't do but I was supposed
to be doing was working in the Umbrella
Factory so I paid a local boy to do it
um I've got a pop-up umbrella from there
I thought
you know you really get a perspective
about I want to just simple
discrimination but being an outsider a
foreigner the way sometimes people feel
picked upon you know we were called the
white trash and we were in in Chains and
everything so I knew I had to cover my
face in the popular did it and I managed
to get to
a place where a passport was hidden and
to the airport and still had a working
ATM card to get me out of the country
into Singapore so did you end up with
the umbrella did you walk out the front
gate yeah I did I had some long trousers
on now in their prisoners are not
allowed to wear them so I had some khaki
pants I thought they might as I walked
around the the narrow path to the front
gate it's still mote but a little Bridge
I thought another figure it's a guard
arriving late and sneaking in and I did
I felt like Ripley an alien uh looking
at thinking lucky lucky this is where it
all ends doesn't it and I'm thinking
that every moment and looking up
and there was just enough light rain to
justify the umbrella
yeah I would learn later that was
actually the not a rain from the gods
but the spittle of their laughter
because they had worse things in mind
for me later on I mean it's so it's you
know how many people are you aware how
many people had escaped from that prison
up to that point was it some every year
or was it very infrequent none
um the ties sometimes ran away when they
were doing the gardens in Chains outside
but Escape From Within
um I'd known of in 20 years people could
recall two attempts no foreigners
um and they didn't trust the foreigners
that's why they put you on the third
floor right quite rightly yes
and and how long had it taken you from
like the beginning of the uh I started
cutting at
um 11 45
I paid a lot to get a light switch in
there normally the lights are on all the
time
um okay and I said to my favorite guard
oh yeah Ponting or whatever his name was
I can't sleep with that thing I'll put a
light switch in
um
um now they didn't say it as corruption
or bribe taking they thought I'm doing
this nice guy a favor and I'll be lucky
because of it that's a very big thing
over there you know if I get caught I'm
unlucky then so they can batter me to
death I mean sure it's kind of
self-justifies any action that a human
being might take so he started cutting
around eight for 11 45 11 45 okay it's
quite close through one bar by two in
the morning oh God stencia
listen we'll go on the next note
I looked around and
Kevin the American from Hawaii I didn't
even know this was happening uh Mirage
the Indian I know he's going to talk the
next morning he was kakaria LA pantaloni
right in the cell never mind
holding out and not saying anything he
would have it would have been finished I
never would have made it and I guess I
could have seen the missing bars
potentially but I learned later on I
actually caught up with somebody who was
in there Scottish guy
um he was there for selling ecstasy to
the Two well-off Sons and Daughters of
wealthy policemen anyway
um he remembers they the guards couldn't
figure
that I'd left oh
um he said David they ran around the the
prison calling out your name it was
Daniel Westlake while I was there
Daniel Daniel they okay that somebody
drew their attention to the cut bar in
there
yeah my Scottish friend said they the
gods wanted they thought that okay he's
got out he's angry about something uh
Daniel but he's not actually he'll never
get out he couldn't get it they never
found the the ladder down the front wall
until much much later so for um
uh uh only one of them said oh we better
check the airport they sent a couple of
guys down there
um just a little bit late and you were
gone by then only just and remember man
you've got a passport from a Chinese
connection that you barely know but kind
of like the cut of his jib but are you
gonna put your life on the line on that
and at every moment you're handing it
over you know like the look of it yeah
they don't like the look of it they're
typing it up and you're thinking
they got onto the computer have they
done that bit
uh have they entered my arrival was this
I knew it was freshly stolen or sold off
was only a few weeks old uh I mean not
new was had only gone missing a few
weeks earlier so it was still good
but very nerve-wracking and I didn't
have a photo I had to use my old um
uh radio operators license that had a
photograph in it to get reproduced into
this thing so it was a bit grainy um
and
even on the plane it was delay and
takeoff oh God
and a mumbling Captain oh sorry
um we
we have a thing with one passenger I
just asked what thing exactly
soon enough thwomp doors to manual oh
but I've got an hour you know
looking at this passport I don't like it
get to Singapore but I make it through
so you got to Singapore yeah
but you did end up going
back to prison not a Thai prison but a
different prison he's suggesting uh I
did something wrong well I'm hoping
you're going to tell me
um no well okay
uh I didn't stay in Singapore long
because
um I sat there in the hotel room
unable to digest food not prepared by my
own cook
sure I in the hotel room in Singapore I
realized you could work out who had left
that day if they'd flown my air by
simply going to the airport
and children you work it out yourselves
at home you check everybody who's left
separate the foreigners hmm go a step
further let's keep the Canadian and
American the British the Australian New
Zealand all the English-speaking
passport Society
um just to you know reduce the numbers
take those names check with the
embassies any of these names belong to
lost or stolen passports that have been
reported yeah five of them because
that's Bangkok you know not the only
Mischief maker there but nonetheless
um
they probably knew I could be
who was I
Charles McClintock hmm sorry Charles I
had to borrow your passport but it was
an essential cause but you're not wanted
anymore of course are you no but I did
get an unwelcome knock at the door some
years ago uh by the police who um
would it be to go excuse me Westminster
Court known for the terrorist cases
extradition or parking fights wow I'd
lift the car anywhere lately so it was
going to be one of the other two and it
was extradition to Thailand I fought
that case for two years and
um
it was difficult
um but managed to effectively win in the
end so the ties have dropped that one
and I can't be taken back there I'm not
wanted anywhere
um I can
nobody can do what they want but
um I I'm not I haven't got anything
pending I'm not in business I'm a bit
cautious I even got sent something in
the the mail a few years ago and
I thought it was some gift from some
halfway ambitious wombat in in Pakistan
sending me a bit of dope thinking oh
yeah there's a gift you might like that
connection made no I mean people had my
address all around the world ever since
Danny Dyer
um
it turned out to be more complicated
than that but
um very dangerous for me to walk into a
courtroom so I don't even imagine you're
me
and knock at the door oh here's
something for you Ben
you don't like the look of it
you refuse it you're in court no matter
why did you refuse that was it your name
no you was up The Jig was up proof
ladies and gentlemen oh you accept it ah
you accepted it proof ladies and
gentlemen
wife saying to me Jeanette and whom I
met in Pakistan years ago
and she was there to fish out her
husband on a two-ton hash deal he didn't
make it anyway
um
she said
throw the thing away I'm thinking in
court again
ladies and gentlemen he threw the stuff
away I can't win so very cautious about
all that kind of stuff
um fair enough but I take it you won't
be going for a holiday to Thailand
anytime soon
I didn't think so okay
so how many do you know off the top of
your head of your life how many years of
your life have you spent in prison
ultimately I did add it up once I'm 66
now and I suppose I've spent um
but
22 years the thing that occurs to me and
I met you before and I thought the same
thing is like you obviously extremely
intelligent extremely resourceful it
can't be well but well anyway but do you
regret the choices you made in terms of
do you see those 22 years in prison as
something you had no control over it's
just the way the dice rolled or do you
see them as a mistake on your part
um worse than a mistake mistake suggest
you didn't know uh where you were going
wrong I was taking those steps into uh
of a precipice that I'd defied there is
no gravity I said I said I will work out
something before I hit the ground
um when I was It was kind of in stages
when I was young it was just arrogance
and and showing off
and later on when everything was
destroyed it was kind of
I'd scraped away all of my life and
would just go on
um then in the third stage it was
escaping away from places rebuilding up
and being weakened every time it was
taken away again
um and do I regret it yeah I'm sure I um
no
you know some people say oh
yeah but David just smuggled everything
on Earth you scumbag you you know
um think of the lives you've destroyed
and the people you've heard
ah and I go to start to explain that
it's not quite black and white
uh I mean I've had drug habits myself
that I've carelessly allowed
um but I thought what's the point
anything I say we just sound like
self-justification so well don't listen
to me then you know but things that have
happened that have taught me a lot it's
interesting you say that because one of
a lot of the comments on our well on the
first video we did a lot of the comments
where people saying someone needs to
make a movie about this guy but a lot of
the other comments were people saying
he's so charismatic and likable but he
must be a really dangerous person to
have been involved with all these worlds
for so long and um we've interviewed a
couple of drug smugglers and I would say
they're the ones that I've met have been
the ones that probably are more someone
you'd see is traditionally quite an
obviously dangerous person you come
across as very Charming charismatic
roguish where do you see yourself on
that scale do you see yourself as
someone who was dangerous or do you see
yourself as someone who's just moved
from area to area as it occurred
um kind of like this a dangerous I
suppose what most people see that and
you know if somebody was a problem for
me would I find the best option to have
them killed or not
but really there always was a kind of
Vestige of
that's a failure if you can't think of
anything better than to have them killed
then then then what are you doing
there's a million
clever ways of solving your problems and
that besides which there's always going
to be people you can't kill everybody
um not only that
who killed the killers that you've got
to do the killing you know you know they
always say that about the quiet ones and
all of that but it was the people who
bothered to put up a smoke screen
um they're establishing a um
later Alibi a courtroom personality but
I met him he didn't seem bothered by all
of that why would he have him killed and
those are the ones that um seem to be
more dangerous and if I was such a
dangerous person like that I certainly
been absolute fool to break from that
mold and say otherwise wouldn't it
very true
David it's great to see you again thank
you so much for coming in always a
pleasure yeah and I've Got a Feeling
we'll be seeing you again at some point
as well it's possible it does may cross
thank you I'll be like oh my God they're
in my head they they know they know that
was a song and so they put that song on
the radio and it's all everything
revolves around me or you know
and this happened well sometimes happens
today
you know I'm I'm thinking of someone in
my head someone under there like on the
street